love here welcome back everyone we have
a very special guest at the news desk
someone I am such a fan of he is an
actor and a comedian and apparently he
became best friends with Paul Rudd right
after meeting him at a college party
let's ask him about it it's Robert
um we love Paul Rudd that's super fun
rob Paul is an amazing guy now I don't
know who his best friend is
but I'm a good friend okay I wouldn't
say best friend but I'm sure his best
friend's watching this going what the
heck Paul right I was gonna say like do
also guys do that like girls do that but
do guys do that we rank yeah okay
perfect well Rob we are here at the news
desk oh yeah news would you kindly get
in pull position and read our first
story with me and Rafi yes
absolutely
all right uh hot out of the gates first
up 90s comedies fans you get to Rejoice
according to fandom wire Dumb and Dumber
3 is rumored to be in the works and Jim
Carrey
yeah and Jeff Daniels are set to reprise
their roles as Lloyd and Harry this
means that Jim would have to come out of
the self-imposed retirement that he
announced in 2020. I'm not happy about
that so Drew and Ross uh are you excited
for this or should we not mess with the
Masterpiece well you were in Dumb and
Dumber too right so that's what makes me
think
you were there
I already messed with a masterpiece yeah
so actually I feel like you're an
authority so I gotta say one of the one
of the highlights a very surreal moment
was when I was in a scene first scene of
the movie with Lloyd and Harry Lloyd and
Harry in a hearse and my head in the
middle I was in the back of the hearse
yeah and um actually the first take I
forgot that I had lines because I was
just going this is amazing yeah it's so
cool so surreal so I don't know I think
the world could always use a little more
uh
I think Jim Carrey Jim Carrey can come
out of retirement Cher goes in and out
every single week right exactly exactly
I would absolutely watch when the the
second one was called dummy number two
like t-o what would you call the third
one like the most dumbest yeah the the
uh yeah let me um I had one I was
thinking about earlier too uh and then
just flown out of my mind because I was
thinking I think oh oh never not dumb
never not dumb is great double negative
yeah exactly something like that maybe
exactly I I need Jim Carrey you know I
watch his films obsessively with my
daughters the other day we were watching
liar liar and I'm I'm just staring at
him I mean he is he is such a National
Treasure it's like whether I'm watching
the new Sonic movies with him or you
know I just posted on Instagram this
like a series of him doing physical
impressions for photographs for his like
In Living Color audition like there's
there's never been a time where I can
remember like life without Jim Carrey
almost and I can't I don't there there
should be no life without Jim Carrey I I
need it
agree I hope this is true and you're
right that that scene in Liar Liar where
uh he comes into the boardroom and he
just goes around the room the best that
might be the best one minute of of film
ever comedy I mean it's just I've never
seen it and not laughing all right next
up Associated Press reports Carol
Whitley of Ontario Canada has officially
been crowned the champion of key West's
annual conch shell blowing contest in
the women division we're obsessed take a
look at this
oh
yeah okay that is some Talent right
there I always wondered if like this was
hard to do have you ever tried it before
blowing a conch shell yeah have you rob
yes you have well I wasn't sober
unfortunately
it was it was a mess yeah it was down on
a beach and uh I felt like I did a good
job and I don't know well you want to
prove it because look what we got here
hey come on get in
is this a is this a real this is a real
one you can blow it I we're blowing a
lot today Rocky
yeah
you got some pipes and on those lines
all right Rossi let's harmonize ready
that was the worst that was the worst to
do it
lasted
well clearly Rob is the winner we suck
show us one more time how it's done
I'm Gonna Give It Up to Carol now I was
like that was sort of short and sweet I
didn't realize what she pulled off Carol
way to blow Carol
oh
yeah
okay finally countries all over the
world are trying to phase out single-use
plastic and go coffee cup lid free
because they are one of the biggest
offenders so enter a company called the
good cup and Fast Company which is one
of the most reputable sources reports
it's a new recyclable compostable coffee
cup that folds up like a miniature
takeout box and the designer spent three
years honing it in and it's already
launched in the UK and Japan it's on
trial in Australia and hopefully we will
see it here in the U.S soon now Rob
um I am really excited about your
documentary we purposefully told this
story I work with a company Grove I'm
trying to improve my carbon footprint
what is your documentary and when do we
get to watch it because I just want to
learn more uh I was very lucky I met
this wonderful lady Janice overbeck and
she has made a movie with Jack winch and
they made a movie it's called plastic
Earth you can see it at plastic
earthmovie.com it's out right now we're
going to push to it on all our social
channels
um but they they do so they do what what
I learned was
um there are it's so much Doom and Gloom
out there when you talk about the
environment and when people talk about
their environment sometimes it's a lot
of Shame and blame and here's the thing
we need plastic we need it we function
on it it's part of our life it's part of
what we do it's we're not getting rid of
it but it takes 100 years to decompose
it takes it's we have a problem we have
a problem with it so this we talk about
Solutions and I love it because the good
news is there are so many amazing
engineers and scientists all over the
world right now working on this problem
coming up with great great ways that we
can uh help save our oceans help save
our plan to help get those microplastics
out of our water supply get them out of
our food supply and all it takes is just
a little effort on our part just a
little bit and if we each do little
things we're going to make a huge
difference this is going to be uh
and the solution otherwise I Rebel and
tune out yeah Rob briggle plastic Earth
is now available on VOD and digital
including Amazon iTunes and anywhere
where you buy movies again we are going
to push to it like maniacs on all of our
socials and next there's a thing called
a spinach artichoke dip you know Rob oh
yes right okay murder one of those me
too I could motorboat it so pasta and
spinach artichoke dip just had a baby
and we're gonna go taste it over in the
kitchen
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]